hey 42 here you've heard a snake
charming you may have even hypnotized
the chicken but I bet you've never heard
of worm charming in what may be one of
the most British events in existence
every year the little village of
Williston in northern England hosts the
world worm charming Championships yeah
it's exactly what it sounds like
charming wormed out of the ground from
chasing a wheel of cheese down a hill to
racing snails the British really do know
how to turn any old crap into a
competitive sport every year hundreds of
thrill-seekers gather in the picturesque
little village of Williston to compete
in an intense championship of global
proportions the world worm charming
championships began in 1980 when some
village locals were so bored that they
decided to challenge each other to
coercing worms out of the ground by
rapidly tapping on the grass they
thought it was so thrilling that they
made a competition out of it and it has
since grown massively in popularity some
people travel from all over Europe to
attend so how does one charmer work the
basic idea is to create vibrations in
the ground which scares the worm to the
surface one's day wiggle out of the
ground they must be picked and placed
into a plastic cup now this is more
difficult than it seems if they're
picked too soon or too fast then it's
easy to snap the worm in two incomplete
worms won't be counted by the judges
vibrations are created by all kinds of
methods one of the most popular is
jamming a pitchfork into the soil and
repeatedly hitting it to send shockwaves
into the ground
others opt for more unusual techniques
such as imitating the sound of rain
which worms are naturally drawn towards
and even playing the sound of rainfall
into the soil with speakers of as simply
resort to whacking the ground with any
random object that takes their fancy
there was once a woman who's genuine
technique was to tap dance to the theme
from Star Wars but she wasn't able to
turn the worms from the dark side aside
from creating vibrations Moisture is
also a well-used technique wetting the
ground with things such as sugar water
beer and even your we can help to coerce
the worm to the surface people create
all kinds of strange mixtures to use
during the competition however
there's a rule nothing toxic is allowed
to be used and anyone using a liquid
must first take a gulp of it in front of
the competition's official judge the
worm master before using it in the
competition nevertheless people do still
use urine speaking of rules there are 18
of them in worm farming including each
competitor is given a free by free meter
plot no digging or forking is allowed
and all worms must be returned unharmed
to the ground after the competition each
team is made up of three people a
charmer a picker and the counter and no
I haven't said those wrongly I'm fairly
sure you can guess what each of their
roles are the current world record
holder is a ten year old girl who
charmed 567 worms from the ground during
the world worm farming championships in
2009 but the weird world of worms
humming isn't just reserved to an
eccentric village in the north of
England believe it or not there's
another British village that is totally
obsessive worm humming - every year
black horton a village stuck to the
bottom of Britain's big toe otherwise
known as Devon hosts a worm charming
festival the black or tan international
festival of worm shamming is similar to
its northern brother but festivities
also include live music or weekends and
unlike the free square meters provided
at the world championships contestants
at black horton only gets a measly one
square metre to do that charming
fancy-dress is also not an uncommon
sight at the festival the black autumn
festival also has an official sheet
whose job is to encourage and even help
others to cheat often selling black
market worms to contestants to boost
their score despite the fact that the
rules blatantly state any competitor
caught cheating will be publicly
humiliated under squalor fight one
competitor with banned for life because
he concealed worms up his trouser leg
before the event so he could sprinkle
them onto the ground you've really got
to admire someone who would risk worms
slamming up their most personal spaces
just to win a village competition thanks
for watching do you worry about a zombie
uprising well fear not the US Department
of Defense
as you covered the Pentagon has created
a comprehensive plan detailing how to
counter a zombie apocalypse herring or
quite simply the undisputed Nobel Prize
winners of underwater communication
because they use farts to talk to each
other